this is a gooey duck it looks like a
penis
but it's the shellfish it is the largest
burrowing clam in the world and it also
is one of the longest living animals of
any type it is native to the northwest
coast of North America and since we were
in Seattle for a weekend we had to drive
[Music]
so I'm blanching the gooey duck in a hot
water and then going chock it real quick
in some ice water to stop the cooking
real quick the only cooking that we did
was just so we could peel off the outer
skin
[Music]
we have the siphon the belly and the
inner organs you're gonna eat the siphon
and the belly we serve it sashimi-style
it's just thin Ross slices of both the
belly and the siphon gooey dug a little
bit of salt our lemon zest followed by
our shiso oil red pepper curls our
radish roots all right let's see I read
online that it tastes like cucumber it
kind of really does comparison with
clams on oysters
I like this consistency better because
it's not like mucus I think this would
be really good if it was breaded and
deep-fried kind of like calamari now
that would be my [ __ ] because calamari
kind of has the same consistency that's
that would make it for me I'm afraid of
most seafood but I'm gonna face my fears
today whoa the coldness took me by
surprise it's like very cold it's just
like a really tender sushi almost melts
in your mouth and it's fishy but it's
not overwhelming this is pretty good
food it tastes a lot less weird than it
looks
all right Quillin you're up let's try
something new I'm not gonna lie the body
of the shellfish is sort of imposing it
kind of looks like the downstairs part
of a man if you know what I'm saying
but in these thin little slices it's a
very sexy fish oh I had a really hard
time I don't want to make it seem gross
cuz it tastes really good but the way
that it felt in my mouth if you're
someone who eats based on texture it
might not be what you're into pretty
tasty is I feel like yeah the taste wise
it was really good just texture for me
it wasn't the bag but I totally agree
like if you're gonna come here I should
try everything at least once to figure
out if it's for you
[Music]